there is no range to heal
your will
so this coming here
is a bit like it's easy
if I do that the weight of the job being
longer that in the lessons the weight of
the Joe was Sanic
I'll let it sag and I use the body
weight
Bring It Around
almost to do its own cut I just added
some some power of my body to this
free-flying thing
so what Thomas is doing and a lot of
people do this quite natural
they do the first one and then they lift
that end to go there
but that choke without me realizing it
just like the talent that took physical
strength
you might not be able to measure how
much strength that took but it took
strength
so that would go against the Japanese
tongue theory
you can tell I'll put too much time in
there so you know all this information
is ridiculous but it's here you let it
sag but because of my body movement my
body
is keeping this side going so it becomes
effortless because I'm following the
pattern of the Joe not making the joke
follow the pattern of my physical
see these are all physical
so if I want to find something Beyond
physical
so the next thing is some of you
experience once you're doing that and
you're just trying to get home to there
and again it would be like what I call
the Japanese Town your hand is turning
that and putting it there
where what I'm doing is I'm following
the wherever we'll say and when it does
that
I just catch it and gather it back in
so I'm doing that but look really
I'm sort of waiting for it to come back
and then I am out to her
about days try to teach
whatever I know and it's up to you each
individual to take home what you liked
from that
and you might think yourself I don't
know when I'm about to get that that's
it that's its hearing you'll get it when
you're ready to get it you might be
walking down to the supermarket go
that's what he means and if anybody
stood next to you they think you've gone
a little bit crazy but for you
some things come together
so so I'm not saying
do that
but I'm saying at least
think
that the next stage where if you're
there think of
Congress said so you get out there and
bring it in Edge I mean think about that
what I'm doing is
there it is
because it's so easy for my hand to turn
it but this hasn't got any power it's
just like it's just gonna oh well just a
minute let's get it there and let's
start again I'm saying there is no age
there is no range to heal
your will
important